the amazing pole vaulter the mysterious
man with 1 000 false IDs these aren't
Marvel characters they're Marvel actors
though it was a bit of a surprise when
it was first announced Woody Harrelson
wound up playing the villain Cletus
Cassidy AKA Carnage in 2021's venom Let
There Be Carnage he also has a bit of
history when it comes to the law in 1982
as detailed in an interview with The
Hollywood Reporter Harrelson was
arrested for jaywalking and things got
out of hand as Harrelson recalled he and
an unnamed friend were the victims of
police brutality after being stopped for
jaywalking the actor said it was so
brutal the way they were handling me a
bunch of students gathered around and
were complaining to the cops and the
cops were vicious to them too according
to Harrelson the incident culminated in
him being maced to prevent him from
fleeing the scene before he was taken to
jail with six separate charges against
him he added that was a real eye-opener
and in eye closer at the same time
because it really my eyes I had to wear
sunglasses for a long time though this
incident was by no means the last of his
encounters with the law the three-time
Academy Award nominee long time cannabis
activist and vegan lives a less eventful
life these days hopefully he manages to
stay out of the kind of Limelight that
leads to more mug shots if you're gonna
treat me like a baby I'm gonna act like
one
despite the fact that Josh Brolin's
first foray into the world of comic book
adaptations with Jonah Hex was largely
unsuccessful he was clearly not turned
off the genre he later portrayed two
major Marvel characters Cable in
Deadpool 2 and the Avengers ultimate foe
Thanos despite earlier encounters with
law enforcement the actor's experience
with mugshots didn't begin until 2008.
he was arrested for interfering with an
arrest outside a bar in Shreveport LA
along with Marvel co-star Jeffrey Wright
while neither actor has given much
insight into the event Roland did state
in W magazine it was nice to be in jail
knowing that I hadn't done anything
wrong and it was maddening to be in jail
knowing that I hadn't done anything
wrong in 2013 the actor had a second
encounter with police in Santa Monica
just before midnight on New Year's Eve
while intoxicated and pole vaulting down
the street near his home according to
Santa Monica Police Lieutenant Daryl
Lowe Brolin was booked and then released
approximately six hours later once he
had sobered up the actor has since
stated that it was a significant moment
for him via the guardian he said I
realized that I was on a destructive
path I knew that I had to change and
mature
while Jeffrey Wright is a newer addition
to the Marvel Canon his relationship
with fellow Marvel veteran Josh Brolin
goes back far beyond his time in the MCU
he plays The Watcher a cosmic being who
serves as the narrator of what if there
is still hope for this universe as
previously mentioned Roland and Wright
were arrested in Shreveport LA outside
of stray cat bar where the pair had been
attending a wrap party for their film W
back in 2008 following a report of cast
and crew members refusing to leave
despite being asked the police were
summoned when Roland and Wright stepped
in to attempt to Defuse The Situation
they were restrained on charges of
interfering with an officer via Action
News 5. witness accounts along with a
video of the arrest which was released
by The Associated Press suggests
possible police misconduct TMZ reports
at the time indicated that Wright was
tasered multiple times and pepper
sprayed cited witness statements claim
foul racially fueled language being used
by police officers unfortunately despite
multiple witness reports the Shreveport
Police Department ultimately deemed that
their officers had responded with
professionalism also none of the fellow
officers who had previously attested to
witnessing the tirade had officially
come forward
while the star of the original Blade
series will not be returning for the MCU
reboot Wesley Snipes place in Marvel
history will never be forgotten Snipes
has had several encounters with law
enforcement but it wasn't until 2008
that the U.S Marshals actor had his
mugshot taken by none other than the U.S
Marshals service themselves after his
arrest the actor faced charges for
failing to file tax returns between 1999
and 2004. a period wherein he had
accrued nearly 40 million dollars though
he offered to pay approximately 842
thousand dollars of his 23 point million
dollar debt Snipes was fined 5 million
dollars and given a three-year prison
sentence according to people he was
released from prison in 2013 after which
he quickly resumed his acting career
appearing in films such as Chiraq
Dolomite is my name and coming to
America the latter film would see him
reprise his role from the 1980s cult
comedy classic Coming to America
starring Eddie Murphy in 2020 Snipes
rest re-entered the public Focus due to
the apparent hypocrisy of the US
government for not arresting former
president Donald Trump after accusations
of tax evasion the actor's arrest and
federal prison time were seen in a new
light with many people calling for
apologies to be made including author
Sam J Miller who wrote Wesley Snipes and
Lauren Hill had their careers destroyed
oh and they went to jail for failing to
pay taxes
the original Roadie to rdj's Tony Stark
Iron Man co-star Terence Howard has had
a tumultuous personal life the academy
award-nominated actor had his mugshot
captured twice both times related to an
assault on a woman in the year 2000
Howard was arrested after a flight
attendant accused him of grabbing her
during a disagreement surrounding the
fastened seatbelt sign according to ABC
News while charges were not pursued
after his 2000 arrest the details behind
his 2001 mug shot are a bit more complex
as cited by the Chicago Tribune and The
Smoking Gun in 2001 Howard admitted to
striking his first wife Lori McComas
prior to their divorce he stated via
Rolling Stone she was talking to me real
strong and I lost my mind and slapped
her in front of the kids the White Marsh
Police Department report details the
argument that immediately preceded the
event wherein the actor warned over the
phone per The Smoking Gun don't
disrespect me by hanging up on me or
I'll come over and hurt you the coma is
still hung up she then called 9-1-1
afraid of what Howard might do leave
attack ended when Howard's brother
entered mccomas's home the brother saw
Howard's storm out of his house to go to
the victim's house and followed in 2002
the actor pleaded guilty to disorderly
conduct in relation to the incident
in 2003's Hulk Nick Nolte portrayed
David Banner the genius who served as
both father and origin story for Eric
bana's Bruce Banner while the film might
not be the Hulk's definitive appearance
Nolte's depiction of the doomed
researcher Remains the only iteration of
the character within the modern MCU
Nolte's first significant run-in with
authorities occurred in 1961 when the
three-time Academy Award nominee was
arrested in Omaha this was following a
bizarre series of events involving a
pack of 1 000 falsified IDs falling out
of a non-functional hearse of the event
Nolte has stated I don't think it was an
intentional criminal act it was
stupidity while he was convicted and
sentenced to a 45-year prison stint the
sentence was ultimately suspended
according to Esquire in 2002 almost
exactly one decade after being declared
People's sexiest man alive Nolte had his
photo snapped following his arrest for
driving Under the Influence Nolte
described the event in his Memoir
writing I was a mess and driving on the
Pacific Coast Highway I'm told six
drivers called 9-1-1 to report a big
sedan weaving on the wrong side of the
road despite significant evidence to the
contrary Nolte himself has claimed that
the photo in question was closer to
being a souvenir for one of the officers
present at the station
Hollywood Superstar Nicholas Cage was
already a well-seasoned actor by the
time he revved up audiences in 2007's
Ghostwriter this was a role he committed
to with the exact amount of hyperactive
enthusiasm he has been famous for since
his rival on the Hollywood scene way
back in 1981. his self-branded Nouveau
shamanic style of acting has earned him
one Academy Award and there's no sign of
him slowing down anytime soon though
there have been some false claims within
Cage's legal history the actor
definitely interacted with law
enforcement when a mug shot was taken
after the actor was arrested in New
Orleans during what appeared to be a
domestic dispute on the street onlookers
fly down police outside of residence in
the French Quarter in 2011 upon arriving
at the scene the responding officer
noticed immediately that cage was
heavily intoxicated
tell you the truth I'm a little shaky
right now he then escorted him down to
Central Lockup according to Reuters the
actor was photographed and processed
before being bailed out by none other
than Dwayne Dog the Bounty Hunter
Chapman after the case was reviewed by
the District Attorney's office it was
deemed that there was insufficient
evidence to charge cage with a criminal
offense according to CNN the District
Attorney's office did not give Nick Cage
any breaks because of his status at the
same time we are not going to judge him
more harshly either
Marvel's favorite leading man Robert
Downey Jr first started portraying Tony
Stark in 2008's Iron Man the film that
marked the official beginning of the MCU
not entirely unlike his on-screen bad
boy Persona RDJ himself has been
arrested on multiple occasions primarily
in association with drug-related charges
his long struggle with addiction and
Recovery has been covered many times
over some of his stories can be told
with a more tongue-in-cheek tone these
days like his arrest for smoking
cannabis in Disneyland however the
arrests associated with the actor's
three most accessible mugshots are more
serious in 1996 he was arrested for
possession of cocaine and heroin as well
as a handgun following another arrest
two weeks later involving breaking and
entering RDJ entered the beginning of
his recovery process according to the LA
Times this included two in-custody
programs two residential programs and
two Rehabilitation programs following
his failure to submit to three separate
drug tests in 1999 the actor was
arrested and sentenced to three years in
prison where his first mug shot was
captured the subsequent two mug shots
were taken following similar
drug-related arrests in 2000 and 2001
respectively Downey Jr has since stated
that he's been sober since 2012. he said
in an interview with Oprah for me I just
happened to be in a situation the very
last time and I said you know what I
don't think I can continue doing this
don't do anything I would do and
definitely don't do anything I wouldn't
do there's a there's a little gray area
in there and that's where you operate
while Mickey Rourke has expressed
regrets about his role in the Marvel
Universe his portrayal of Ivan vonko AKA
Whiplash was an interesting introduction
to Iron Man as it turns out Rook himself
is no stranger to encounters with the
law though his 1994 charge of resisting
rest and allegation of spousal abuse
came first the arrest associated with
this mugshot didn't occur until 2007. on
November 8 2007 the actor was arrested
for driving Under the Influence
following a traffic stop attributed to
an illegal u-turn on his motorized
scooter in Miami Beach for Reuters the
arresting officer said of the incident
work had bloodshot watery eyes slurred
speech and a strong odor of an alcoholic
beverage he was placed under arrest even
though the actor denied the allegations
at the time being though the former
boxers transitioned into Hollywood life
and his history with substance use and
personal struggles are known to have
taken a toll on him he claims to have
found means of recovery in recent years
he publicly thanked his agent David a
Unger his priest and weekly sessions
with a psychiatrist for aiding him in
his recovery and subsequent comeback if
you or anyone you know is struggling
with addiction issues help is available
visit the Substance Abuse and Mental
Health Services Administration website
or contact samhsa's National helpline at
1-800-662-help that's 1-800-662-4357
[Music]